[Musique]
un effort de guerre à 8000 km du front
ici les armes sont des nains à souder et
des marteaux cette usine de blindée a
mis 600ga en Ontario n'a jamais été
aussi occupé le gouvernement du Canada
diète pas assez une grosse commande à
l'entreprise Rochelle
de 200 véhicules blindés destinés aux
forces ukrainiennes annoncent la
ministre de la défense de passage à Kiev
pour répondre à la demande l'usine
tourne 24 heures sur 24 sur le plancher
Rochelle peut compter sur une force
spéciale 80
Ukrainiens récemment arrivés au Canada
I'm Aznavour
je dois faire ma part 17 craignais qui a
préféré faire son nom ses parents sont
toujours en Ukraine
mais très loin il a l'impression avec
son travail devenir en aide à sa famille
reçoit de la rétroaction en temps réel
la force ukrainiennes et apportent des
modifications à ces véhicules avec
people understand des responsable
en pleine guerre les travailleurs ici
sont conscients de la responsabilité qui
leur estombe explique-t-il celle de
protéger les soldats Ukrainiens
si des entreprises et des travailleurs
d'ici sont fiers de contribuer à
l'effort de guerre le gouvernement
Trudeau
lui dans le milieu de la défense la
contribution canadienne aurait pu être
plus rapide et surtout beaucoup plus
significative la crise ukrainienne a
exposé des lacunes ici au Canada
le patron des Forces canadiennes
déclaraient que le secteur de la défense
devait être sur le pied de guerre
après le début de la guerre l'industrie
canadienne attend toujours un signal
clair d'Ottawa
que le gouvernement soit plus proactif
pour faire connaître ses besoins
le Canada aurait la capacité
industrielle par exemple de produire
beaucoup plus de munitions pour
l'Ukraine comme des obus d'artillerie de
155 mm essentiels au front
les soldats Ukrainiens on utilise
environ 5000 par jour et les réserves
s'épuisent mais le gouvernement fédéral
tarde à signer des contrats à long terme
et à augmenter les commandes
aurait dû être prise il y a six mois un
an disent les représentants de
l'industrie jusqu'ici le Canada a livré
27000 obus de 155 mm à l'Ukraine de quoi
tenir à peine 5 jours au fond et les
trois quarts ont été achetés des
Américains c'est les Américains étaient
pas là s'il n'avaient pas leur grande
stock et la volonté de faire des grands
contributions les Ukraine sera fichu en
effet le symptôme de problème beaucoup
plus large selon ce lieutenant général à
la retraite et ex député dans l'équipe
de Justin Trudeau il estime que
l'inventaire des Forces canadiennes a
été négligée ces dernières années par
Ottawa et que 15 milliards de dollars du
budget de la défense n'ont tout
simplement pas été dépensés depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir libéraux le
résultat est qu'on peut pas envoyer des
équipes en vraiment modernes à les
ukrainer et aussi on manque des
capabilités critiques pour nos forces
les besoins présents de l'Ukraine
révèlent des failles l'armée canadienne
est à court de certaines armes
stratégiques
la semaine dernière le Canada a annoncé
l'achat d'un système de défense
anti-aérien aux Américains destinés à
l'Ukraine au coût de 400 millions un
type d'armes absents de l'Arsenal
canadien depuis des années malgré les
appels répétés de haut dirigeants
militaires le système est vraiment cassé
on a besoin d'une leadership du Premier
ministre du ministre des Finances elle
nous Leslie très seule constat sévère le
grand lacent et qu'on a besoin d'un
investissement
à long terme pour les Forces canadiennes
manque de volonté politique ou de vision
à long terme le Premier ministre admet
du bout des lèvres qu'il faut investir
davantage on doit être prêt pour pouvoir
aider dans un monde de plus en plus
instable et pour ça on va continuer
d'investir dans nos forces armées à
l'usine de blindé de mission gaz les
travailleurs Ukrainiens n'ont qu'une
chose en tête
la victoire et l'espoir que l'ardeur de
leur travail puisse servir d'inspiration
en faire plus ici Louis Blouin
Radio-Canada